all right and welcome to the podcast
what do you have to say about the syrian
refugees
nothing do you know anything about syria
i know they have good celery
wow i know they
are um
syrians they they're serious a lot of
times
yeah they're for descendants from the
assyrians
all right can we can we just start over
this was like uh
all of a sudden let's just start over
okay
i know they love cereal all right this
is starting now
all right three two one welcome
[Music]
now we're starting and
we're just conversing about comedy
all right welcome to the podcast um
what's the podcast name
pinky in the brain
uh picking the brain working title dude
let's i was thinking we could just have
a different
name every podcast yeah that way it'll
be impossible to find
um no i mean we keep it the same channel
we just change the name
every time we call this episode false
start
um okay so
let's like let's recap what's going on
right now
uh in we had a guest in your home
yesterday who
no what are you doing don't talk about
that
why because
it's rude i mean
it happened
um dude let's just start over
okay dude we need to like actually
we need to do it serious and like
everyone loves a good serious podcast i
mean uh
but we need i mean we need to have
boundaries
yeah boundaries are good
i don't know what is your favorite
boundary
um my favorite boundary is
maybe the israeli-palestine boundary
that's a great boundary we shouldn't
cross that boundary
a boundary is a limit uh
push it to the limit yeah city limits
austin city limits what do you think
about smoking in bars
i think it should be allowed and i
think that it's up to the bar to allow
it but what about
the employees that are forced to work in
a space
don't work at the bar so you're gonna
limit economic
opportunity for people who want to live
a long healthy life
look if it's a smoking bar it's not
gonna it's probably
they probably dude nobody gives a [ __ ]
like no like people work at bars smoke
like the type of people that work at
bars smoke what about the 30
of people that don't dude then they can
go work at a [ __ ] cat part
or so you're limiting their
opportunities well cat bars are
eliminating people's opportunities
people are allergic to cats
but that's not everyone everyone yeah
exactly
everyone's the same thing everyone has
to breathe
um yeah and everybody has to
be alive and if i'm allergic to i think
the world is a better place if
there are bars that aren't toxic and
smell shitty dude i
just think you want to control people
for some reason
i want to breathe i want to be able to
go into bars and not have to
step outside every five minutes like
city limits
i don't like being there because oh is
that a smoking bar
yeah um well don't go there
i don't yeah but i wish i could
um so i have a variety of drinks today
you have three you know i have one
this one's a people pleaser this one's
for the kids
and then this one is uh let's try to get
sponsored by topo chico
yeah that's important corporate approval
yeah corporate approval is always feels
nice
it feels you it's like getting a dollar
as a kid
yeah did you get an allowance as a kid
yeah i think so how much was it
like three bucks or something
yeah uh
mine was three pesos
uh didn't allowance is important for a
child to learn
how to spend money
um i think
i don't know i don't think it matters
yeah i mean we deal with other resources
as kids like
pencils or you know that we have to
manage and not spend frivolously
so i don't know i think it's all right
to have allowance
but uh yeah i mean i'd love
uh to make money and if we can make
money just off this podcast
then we wouldn't need to work at a
shitty job we could just do what we love
and get paid for it that's ideal so
let's just do things we love until one
of those things get us
gets us paid uh
yeah sure
so just instead of like going
to apply for jobs or like delivering
groceries
we should just like constantly do things
that we love to do that has a
dude but like i do need money like what
do you
what do you want me to do i'm not
criticizing you for
working i'm just saying like maybe
that's an equally good
strategy is to do things you love until
one of them starts making you money
thinking long term investing in your
future
yeah my future is a risky stock
if i were to bet against you i think
that would be a very foolish if i were
to short
your stock i think that would be thanks
man
very dangerous 100 on the
riley
on riley failing i'll take 100 on riley
failing
yeah well you know i think uh
i like uh i want to do like a lot of
things too
like rap
rap shore wrap gifts
presents
comedy so do you think the south pole
has elves and stuff
penguins maybe the l's or just penguins
um i saw this video uh
that said like santa claus was
um originally this magic mushroom
like shaman and like the village shaman
and like when the village got snowed in
he would have to drop the
he would drop the shrooms down the
chimney
oh i guess it was like because the snow
is so high yeah
and he would be like wearing a red suit
and um why a red suit
because santa and then
and and then they would like trip balls
and like
can you imagine if you're starving in
your snowed out house and someone just
gave you drugs
what the [ __ ] give us bread
do you think drugs will be even fun if
you're starving
yeah you did it hit you fast because
there's nothing in your stomach
yeah yeah it'd just be like smoking
um yeah i mean why do you think people
like drugs so much because our brains
are very powerful
and they're bored
just going through normal life we need
to stimulate them
um
yeah well it's kind of like not really
stimulating it's kind of like
i mean it's stimul i feel like it's more
like physically stimulating than
mentally
stimulating
yeah so you feel good you feel yeah it's
stimulating it's kind of like putting
your brain like
out of circuit for a bit yeah it's like
putting it in happy juice
it's just like yeah it's just like
punching it or just like squeezing it
or sucking it or yeah massaging it um
i uh yeah
yeah your brain is uh so like
it's funny how we all we do is wanna
like
get you know wasted or faded
um as a culture and it's just like
that just shows you how little we give a
[ __ ] or
like uh yeah
or it's just like i don't know it's just
like is that
is that the thing you want to do have
you seen that rick and morty where
he goes rick morty's dad goes into that
realm where it's like his babysitting
where they all his dad is it's like a
room full of his dad
getting babysat
um yeah and like in the beginning stages
they're all like fixing the
cable or they're playing in the ball pit
but then once you get to the lower
levels they're all like doing drugs and
smoking and playing people yeah yeah i
think like at the
end of the day like that's what we
really want is just
right we bypass all the
normal circuitry we're like oh you're
supposed to do something good and you
get rewarded for it but we're like oh i
can just skip all that [ __ ]
and just directly make it feel good like
if you have that button
and especially in our if you're living a
depressing life
then i think that becomes more alluring
and it's important to keep your brain
healthy
if you're living a depressing life so
making it happy is very
important for your brain muscle yeah
yeah it's like um
it's like a cheat code
yeah it's like
cheat code with consequences it's like
it's like a cheat it's like
it's like you cheated you're cheating
your teacher sees you cheating
but she's gonna stab you after this
what about weed there's not too many
consequences with that
um yeah there is
you're looking at right now i mean
you're great you're
a funny comedian you're uh great at
timing
because of weed no i'm horrible at
timing because of weed
you're i have a comedic timing i have a
slow
i have i i feel like i feel like eeyore
or like um
i feel like a snail a slug yeah that's
funny
yeah well it's it doesn't like feel
great you know it's just like i want to
use my brain
fully like how it's supposed to be maybe
that's how it's supposed to be
oh why why i don't if that's how it's
supposed to be then
i wouldn't have to do it i don't have to
get high
maybe you would have been like just
without me automatically
i would have been like this anyways
i don't think so dude because like i
think i was a different person
before i started smoking weed well you
obviously like it
so you have a personality that likes
weed
um that's true
and you've grown with this drug and it's
altered your brain
into what it is now which i don't think
is a bad thing
um
yeah i mean whatever
i mean what is the ideal way you want to
be
i want to be like uh
and i want to be like intelligent with
my words like
i want to be concise
and you know uh
i'm going to be i want to put my words
together easily and
and i have a big vocabulary and know how
to speak
so you want to be british
[Music]
loquacious um
i think like the way that you are is
good because like it takes a while but
like once it comes out it's like very
accurate you're very authentic
it's like whatever it comes out is like
what you actually think about whatever
you're talking about
and i think that's good i think if
you're just like fast and just
using big words and you'd sound like a
salesman or like a shuckster
a shockster yeah a sharker what's a
shark moisture
shuckster a sharkster is like a con man
like someone is trying to sell you a
used car
um
yeah i don't know why anyone would do
that job
dude like uh
yeah i mean i tried sales man it's just
like dude like
you gotta be like a a true you gotta be
a true
uh
um guy who's like
who doesn't give a [ __ ] about anything
to be a sales like you you just like
it's like all about the sale
yeah just like i mean
you can still give a [ __ ] but i was just
like like
like the way i like trick people i like
it's not even tricky but it's just like
yeah i mean it's just like faking a
conversation
yeah you gotta say whatever you have to
to get the sale whether it's true or not
and you have to have a loose definition
of the truth yeah
and it's just like the way i like to be
a way i like to talk to people it's just
like
uh i like to
try to learn things about them and you
know really connect with them on you
know
a personal level yeah and really know
their deepest
darkest secrets
what are you gonna do with that
information i have a book
of everyone's deepest darkest secrets
that's great um so useful
but uh maybe we can connect with each
other without
revealing terrible things about
ourselves
i don't know if that is always what
defines us
um no i know i was just joking
or i mean yeah sometimes i don't know
what to talk to people about like i'm
just like
other than like oh like where are you
from like
what do you do for work what do you like
doing uh
um where are you from how many siblings
do you have
do you have healthcare what do you think
about
israel-palestine what's the main
what's the what's your ideas
what is your deepest darkest secret
my deepest darkest secret is
that um
inside jokes dude would you just do a
podcast like uh
where we just do inside jokes yeah no
one will get it
like vomiting into the trash can
yeah inside jerk i mean everybody
everybody does that longest chode
longest showed hilarious
it's one of my closers
[Laughter]
you guys like a tan hey i
i really like when i'm playing catan and
i get longest showed
this guy looks like he has the longest
chode
two victory points for you sir
[Laughter]
oh dude wow
i'm gonna tug and grow my foreskin back
again
yeah that's a good one yeah you should
do that man
tug and grow
my horror skin
because only people who are [ __ ] have
foreskins
so um what do you want to talk about
what do you guys want to talk about how
do you like having a foreskin
um are your parents hippies
uh it's uh
no dude um my mom is just like
she was like i didn't want i didn't want
your uh i didn't want you to be hurt as
a baby
i want your little baby
oh baby riley [ __ ]
and um that was iceberg i guess
yeah very nice it's terrible
to cut off a baby's foreskin that's so
crazy that we do that pretty jewish of
us
we're being so jewy
but it's not just the jews it's also
like
oh cool we can modify our bodies it's
like a tattoo
um yeah what do you how do you feel
about tattoos
i feel great about them i wish i had
enough significant moments in my life
that would warrant me getting a tattoo
um why do you need a significant moment
because i don't want to mark my body for
no reason i
want a market for a reason that's what
everyone
says dude but like in the end you're not
really
you're not you're not marketing for a
reason you're marketing because you want
to get a
tattoo and you're just like you'll be
like uh
i need to wait for the special stars to
a line
on my arm it's not like a it's not like
a
it's a tattoo that like god made it's
just like
you go to a guy he makes your body
i just don't have a cooler an expertise
in picking tattoos
you don't you just pick the one you like
you should get like uh
i'm not good at that so i don't want to
pick the wrong thing aesthetic
you're going it's a hard thing to get
into it's like it is
i feel that skydiving yeah
it's just like once you're in you're it
yeah like
and then like you get and then you're
hanging out with god people with tattoos
and then they're like
oh let me see your ties you only have
one tattoo
yeah dude you need to get tattoos you
can get more tattoos and i'm like oh do
i
like [ __ ] then you're covered in trying
to get myself
into because i don't want to be like
that person that has a bunch of shitty
tattoos
um yeah you mean everyone with tattoos
yeah everyone's tattoos suck
i don't get it dude dude you don't have
tattoos no i don't i don't know if i'll
ever get one
it's like i've always been like uh yeah
i mean
but then i mean it yeah do you think
after you get a tattoo you're just
automatically
cooler
i think it shows that you're more
carefree
that you're willing i don't give a [ __ ]
about my body
i don't care about being employed
yeah that's what people with gages do i
guess gages aren't
what i mean why are
why is that bad to have a tattoo
once just like circumcision it's like
a symbol that you belong to the group
and you're like oh you belong to the
reptile
snake eating sword swallowing group
then go with them and live in the circus
don't come to an office
yeah but now everyone has tattoos
freak everyone's an out out
show have you been to a freak show
no sword swallower
like the guy dan that hosts the open mic
because he swallows swords he sticks
things in his face
up his butt and his butt face
um dude i saw this like in new orleans i
saw this street performer
and it was like a really really good
show
like he he brought the crowd in like he
knew
what to say to the crowd like he was
telling jokes and they were like funny
ass jokes
and and he just knew exactly what to do
in every single moment he was doing
tricks and stuff but like the main part
of the show
really would like the glue of the show
was like him
speaking to the audience and like
connecting with the audience and like
doing
making everyone come together and it was
just like
a really good show you could tell he's
practicing a lot yeah
and i was like damn dude that guy is
[ __ ] talented man
cause like he he did that show while he
was doing like all these crazy stunts
and [ __ ]
we're just talking i think it's easier
to make jokes when you're like i'm gonna
swallow a sword in five seconds
right yeah because you know you're
wasting their time for a reason
yeah um and everyone's like tensed up
yeah
you can easily break the tension right
yeah i feel that
maybe we should start swallowing swords
yeah i'm going to wallow short but first
what's up with dentists
i don't like supporting local stormers
or whatever so i mean yeah i mean
they have it easy because they're good
at that
social situation that they create they
create this tension of sword swallowing
and then in that
arena they're good at navigating the
audience's emotions and then hopefully
we're good at
navigating the audience's emotions that
are just there to see a comedy show or
even when they're not there to see a
comedy show like last night
at shocker shuckers at shuksters
that was so weird just them staring at
us to say they're just eating
because i've been eating at restaurants
and i don't ever remember being like you
know what would be great
at this restaurant right now is if there
were
people talking about penises and sexual
assault
through a loudspeaker yeah i mean like
i was just like hey so what's up with
pedophiles
there they're raping children
and uh they're like dude it's my 12th
birthday today
um no but i actually thought it was uh
not that bad i did like it was it was
good
especially towards the end of the show
or your set
the oyster show you thought the end of
the oyster show was good
yeah people were paying attention to you
or the show the show i mean they might
have been quiet but
i don't think they were enjoying it
what the [ __ ] just happened they were
like traumatized
it's like yeah dude well that one guy
who [ __ ]
complimented us in the back the long
hair
yeah yeah the gorgeous
mane jesus bod
he we weren't listening to a set at all
we were just talking
to the people that we were talking to
um
well you know do what you can
i mean even we didn't care about the
show
i did i mean i did you definitely did
not care about the show
yes i i tried to make it good
by talking out loud in the back of the
bar
it wasn't loud i mean it wasn't quiet
dude yeah that is crazy like you never
know
how loud you're talking like
it's like it's like you think you're
talking quiet sometimes but you're
actually so loud
yeah like people can hear you people
like have like a super
sense hearing yeah that's what our
evolution designed us is to pick up
human
talking pick up when people are talking
about bad about us
we should have gone outside i don't know
why we sat in that bar but i think it's
because like it was a very fragile
because i was talking to some person and
it's like i didn't want them to like go
away
so i was like oh i get to talk to them
right now right here so let's just talk
i don't want to like shake things up or
she might run away
but uh i think if we try to move the
conversation
it would have been difficult so it's
like let's just maintain this
conversation here
and ruin the show it's worth it to have
this conversation
uh yeah
i guess um well i
also look i had a beer
absolutely and plus like i didn't think
i was talking out loud
well i mean whenever you're on stage and
you see comedians not paying attention
it doesn't feel great
and i wish i hadn't yeah but like it
also
i mean yeah it doesn't feel great but
also it's just like whatever as long as
like you're out of the way
like you're not you're not taking away
from the show like you're just a
comedian
like it's not like you're part of the
show you're part of the audience
yeah you're not really there for the
show yeah you're there to perform
so they should do that mental math
but like i i would like to assume that
whenever i start talking people are
interested
so it's like i don't know i think it's
rude and i wish i hadn't done it but
also it's like it was a shitty show
anyway so
i don't really feel too bad but
overall i try not to do that i try if
i'm in the room i try to pay attention
or if i'm not gonna i try to step out
just because i don't want to be
like i don't i don't want a comedian to
see me and be like that [ __ ]
doesn't respect me
i will hold a grudge and i will hate him
forever
yeah but do you think like people
actually think that way like i don't
know i think that way
when you see someone talking you're sad
yeah because it's like this is my career
i thought i was good at this
and if someone's like clearly not
enjoying it then i feel bad
um but like we've as comedians we watch
comedy all the time like
it's like it doesn't it's like it's like
so what like if i don't see it now i'll
see you later like whatever
like it's like it's comedy you know i
whatever yeah whatever it is it's comedy
and i see it a lot all the time
i would like to think it's not just
comedy maybe that i'm doing
another thing adding to the art form
that people can't get other places
we had a good time yesterday
how was uh i was hanging at the creek
saw tony saw whitney cummings
yeah yeah the creek's good but it's just
like
oh overwhelming not overwhelming it's
just like
there's too many powerful people there
i'm afraid i'm gonna [ __ ] up and like
yeah blacklisted from comedy yeah
i know it's just like i don't want to be
edge i don't want to be on edge
yeah i want to relax and just say
whatever i want i want to be able to
yell
balls or dick or vagina
do you do that yeah i've never seen you
do that
well yeah i mean not that but i want to
let loose i don't want to be like oh no
tony's right there i don't want him to
think that i'm a bally vagina type of
guy
yeah what if he started yelling at it
balls vagina i feel like i think
this guy gets me i feel like and then
you both sit at the same time
we get a lot guys
and then you both say vagina at the same
time
violin music starts playing and then we
start a show called kill
tony and hans the kill tony hans version
with an asian twist kill hans
with an asian spicy f
ethan asian flair
uh the sprinkling of kimchi
so um
yeah so this is why i don't want to be
smoking weeds because like i'm really
slow
you know this podcast could be going
fast it could be railing off jokes
but there are people who talk fast who
are boring
yeah well i'm not one of those people
i don't think you should try to talk
fast i think you should just try to talk
slow really well like norm mcdonald
would you go to nor mcdonald and be like
hey speed it up buddy
that's too slow that's true funnier if
you were faster
i mean hey so
um yeah but
yeah so i'm
so i'm slow and yes
stupid stupid and funny and
but i need to be slow and smart and
funny
i need to read books and get
knowledge i need to exercise
yes my body and your mind
my mind my soul your penis
penis your uncircumcised penis
side of sexycomedians.com
um when i was in new orleans they did
this
thing where they they did like a sexy
calendar
of the local comedians
it's pretty funny they have like a good
community down there
nice i didn't know that i thought it was
like mostly
like a drinking party town
yeah it is
but there's a lot of cultural arts and
um you know metrosexual
terminologies i mean flung around
bourbon street um yeah like
pansexual dude um
yeah i was like i went to an open mic
and then outside
outside of that there was like this like
peep show like sexy
circusy freaky like store and it was
right next to like a
slight when i wanted a slice of pizza so
i was like walking and get a slice of
pizza
and i was just like it was just like two
set
like two cents to look at my tits and
like
it was like girl it was like women with
like a bunch of
rings all over her face and uh you know
just like people wearing hats and denim
vests and
you know mustaches and
and i was like and i had like
like and uh sex
it was just like that's what new orleans
is about like uh it's just like
a a different a weird different type of
life
yeah not not like all like sexy stuff
but like
aberrant on this on the fringes of
society
or like testing the limits oh i feel
like in the south they're very uptight
so when you have a bourbon street they
go all out they have to make up for all
the
sex that everyone in the country isn't
having
they come in from the country to new
orleans and they're like let's do all
the things
that are natural and sexual urges that
we've been
repressing dude bourbon street is like
so grimy dude it's like sixth street
it's like six feet on crack dude like
it's like it's like i couldn't even stay
there long because i was like i just
felt like
so right there was just griminess in the
air
you could just feel the the corruption
and the you know the the sexual
deviance in the air you could just you
could
feel the you know just like the devil
basically yeah
just like bad energy and you can feel
that on sixth street too
on bourbon street is way worse and it's
crazy how that stuff sticks around
like sticks to the air like even if even
if you're not religious or spiritual at
all like
you gotta admit like like you can feel
that [ __ ]
yeah um you can feel like a shift in
energy
yeah you're like gotta watch out
someone's gonna try to stick something
inside my butt
on this street i feel a little tingling
in my anus
and you know um i ate a
some gumbo of course and
jambalaya oh
um and some creole and you know creole
creole cajun creole
sounds delicious they're right by the
sea
the mississippi and the gulf
yeah you know good seafood
it's a weird town i mean they're very
free and independent
battle in new orleans
uh yeah they are you know and hey
god bless them you're doing great
keep it up even though you said it's
devilish
and satanic no not all of it
just that
that's the devil the demon of new
orleans
making your hands clumsy
hold on what do you think about
austin's becoming the new comedy city
um i think that
it is uh cool
it's cool we have a head start because
everything's open here and then not i
know
we have the uh first dip we have the
first slice
the first lick texas dude
nothing like a first lick if you're
sharing
a like an ice cream or something that
you have to like both
use the same thing for utensil or
whatever for
dude or like sipping something dude
the first lick nothing like it
okay or like because then
sex with a virgin uh
because you know that i mean you get
like
you don't have to like have their jerk
have their germs like on you
you just have it fresh fresh lick
yeah i'm a bit of a germaphobe the
texture is different
when you're licking something freshly
scoop as opposed to something that's
been licked
yeah that too you know it's like sloppy
it's like a little bit
like wacky and saliva ice cream
yeah second lick
we're first licking austin right now or
are you like
um so like if you're getting into a car
like
if you're getting into a like a backseat
of a car you're like a left
like right right t middle guy like
where are you going
uh probably behind the passenger seat
because then you can ask them to push
the seat forward and you get more leg
room that's true that's a good point
um unless the you know the driver is
shorter than the passenger
yeah that's a good point then you sit
behind the driver
um middle how do you feel about middle
never the middle dude i i i enjoy the
middle sometimes unless there's two
girls
yeah yeah but um you know
the middle is cool because you're kind
of a part of the front of the car
a little bit you know you're like you're
the you're the mediator between
the back and the front of the car you
know you can lean forward you can be
you know you could probably even touch
touch the radio if you needed to
you know you are you have authority you
have ability
you're in the center you yeah you're the
center that's why i like it
the whole car centers around you but
you have that weird razor bump of a seat
what you're raised up a little bit and
it's like a really narrow bump
and your ass is sliding off you know
it's like you're on a top of a hill and
your ass
keeps sliding either way your seat belt
isn't a real seat belt
and if you get into a car crash you're
going straight through the windshield
that's the one thing it's like there's a
lot of risk
but hey risk equals reward
you gotta live a little you gotta live a
little in the middle
look in the middle you can't control the
windows
malcolm in the middle yeah
you have to uh ask people if you want to
change the
climate control dude uh
honestly having posture having good
posture
like hurts does it hurt to you
i mean not when i do it right dude dude
like
it makes my back tired like it's just so
much
stacked up on my back like like the
spine
is just like stacked up yeah you know
and it's just like
if i have it like normally i'm like this
it's like not as much pressure
yeah you're supposed to like slouch
yeah i thought you were supposed to have
good posture i mean if you want to uh
relax like so that you're not yeah
you're supposed to like slouch so that
you're not so
uh tired or like
yeah so you're relaxed because if you're
best yeah
i mean you just want to like lay down or
whatever
as much as possible um
but i thought it was good for you to
like have your spine aligned
when you're walking maybe but if you're
like just laying down
just take all the pressure off um
but uh have you seen that louis c.k
things on a show where he's
going to the doctor and he's like your
spine was meant to be a coat hanger
because we're supposed to walk on all
fours yeah and now we're making it into
a column
so it's not gonna be the perfect tool
for the job
yeah but do you think that's actually
true i mean
yeah gorillas walk on fours but we're
not gorillas
we evolved recently to walk upright
yeah and uh we're still transitioning
we're still working out the kinks dude
it wasn't that recent
well there's like a number you can put
to it we can figure it out and it's like
uh yeah pretty long ago yeah but
not as long as we've been walking on all
fours
um that's not true dude i bet gorillas
weren't invented that long
you don't know anything about your
education
i took a biology course in college
to communicate how little you know about
biology no it was required i went to
liberal arts school
we have not been walking upright a lot
we've been mostly walking on all fours
until recently dude okay think about
think about when humans came about it's
like bc like
[ __ ] trillion 10 000 bc no
yes 200 000 years ago is when
people homo sapiens came about dude what
about 10 000 bc the movie
that was uh that's civilization
civilization was ten thousand years ago
so it was like pre-civilization uh
transition that's twelve thousand years
ago dude i mean
the human was two hundred 000 years ago
200 000 bc
but we've been like neanderthals and
[ __ ] you know or like related to them
like we've been walking up right before
homo sapiens
um
the gorillas that would be crazy bro
if you were gorilla and you just saw
like these these two guys just started
walking upright they're like what the
[ __ ]
what is up with those guys they have no
hind quarters but their front is very
large they get like discriminated
against
we don't serve to we don't serve
stand-up birders in this park
in this bar if we didn't have that we'd
never have stopped
taking your spine get the hell out of
here
yeah knuckle draggers
all right you knuckle draggers
uh
uh
jeff ross had a good roast on shaq i
think it was jeff ross who's like
he's like hey your your knuckles are
scraped shaq
did you walk here
that's funny
[Music]
because he's like animalistic he's just
like yeah
like giant that's
funny on many levels it's like you have
to
use your knuckles to walk and also like
who would walk here
anyways who's walking here hey shaq
i'm walking in hey where who's who's
that
where and where are you walking towards
it's a nice new yorker hey you're
walking there
hey hey i'm walking here but so are you
so it's
all good you know we could get along
you're walking over there but
pedestrians have the right away so i'll
stop
dude uh i like derrick's bit about the
gay new yorker
hey you wanna [ __ ] are we [ __ ] or
what
i like his bit about how all women
are went beautiful you know like or
whatever
i we need to be inclusive to all women
because women come in all shapes and
sizes
it's just that some of those shapes and
sizes are disgusting
that's his joke yeah that's good we're
just doing derek's jokes on our podcast
this shout out derek dimple
i like the dylan jarbo's bit about
cryptocurrency
being used by bloods
i don't know him he's from jacksonville
florida
everyone's coming here everyone's new
here and it's great i love it i think
that we should all be new
nude that'd be great
that would be nice like a nude night a
nude open mic
then we find out who has the biggest
[ __ ]
flaccid [ __ ] let's find out who's turned
on
there's like three people with boners
boner of the night
kevin has a boner put it in
uh i wish there was more orgies
in public um
i would like that not to participate in
but it would be like it'd be like a nice
like
huh yeah this is a welcoming community
nice you can pretty much do anything
here oh that's cool
it's like it's like you know when you
like see like something you know
an event going on you don't want to
really want to participate
you don't really want to participate in
it but you're glad to see it because
you're glad like people are doing stuff
like we're near
you you're like yeah like a farmer's
market yeah
but i actually like farmers markets if
they have like vegetables i went to the
one in austin
it was just like like beeswax
lotion and like cbd and
like [ __ ] stupid [ __ ] dude like
like earrings and like necklaces and
hats i'm like what the [ __ ] i just want
what happened to the farmer part of it
yeah this is just a market
they're just souvenirs it's like
yeah dude it's like [ __ ] you can't sell
at walmart
because it sucks they're like local
businesses
which is cool yeah they're like let's go
to a farmer's market maybe they'll buy
that our [ __ ] there because no one else
buys it
otherwise i think it's our cutco tent
like
well i think that's what happens because
in texas everything's owned by big
corporations so there's no local farmers
everything's like purdue
purdue chickens so that's what i do like
is there
they do sell local meat there and like
if i was a cook if i was cooking a lot
if i had
a good income like that would be great
but i don't
farm to table i need to buy cheap stuff
yeah because you're not a restaurant
also
i'm not rich if i was rich i could buy
farm to table
yeah it's expensive it's expensive
to have good taste to have expensive
taste
it's expensive to not get fat
um that's also true dude like some of
the
like dude like the food insecurity is
like pretty bad in
places like where there's not a lot of
people and there's only like
walmart and like chick chick-fil-a and
[ __ ] like that
yeah uh like
it's like they don't have they you they
don't have the
the nutrients for like they don't have
the
the necessary ingredients
yeah like if they wanted fresh
ingredients they would have to like
drive like three hours away
dude like yeah and it's just like
damn like that's a food desert
it's like the there's like like having
good food in your body is like
like the most important thing like one
of those like that's like one of the
five essential things
yeah and it's like it's not just food
it's like good food like that actually
nourishes you
yeah water that actually quenches
your your body thirst
water is that full of metal and um
shelter is it hazardous and
what's the other ones food food water
job um yeah i thought there's five
things
but uh don't you think that it's because
america
was founded on slavery so we're used to
treating people shitty
um
i mean it's not just slavery it's also
sharecroppers and ventured servants
yeah i mean i'm not saying that's that's
that's a new pattern of
of thinking of doing i'm saying that's
just like
a thing that's happening now that yes
that's like the new plantation houses
or the slaves quarters no i don't think
it's that bad
i think it's pretty slave to your house
they're like just stuck in a little
factory where they don't have any of the
stuff that they need
they're like stuck in like this giant
parking lot basically with no food
and [ __ ] they have to go to fast food
but that's why i like new york because
even if you're in the shitty
neighborhoods you can just take a train
to whole foods
even though it might be far yeah i love
whole foods
so much man it's so good it's so good
you're the people that we were making
fun of in our whole food sketch
and it's just like yeah like like my mom
i'm grateful to my mom who would like
always make organic like good food
and like always go to whole foods and
stuff and now it's just like i gotta eat
like so shitty
yeah but you eat pretty good you eat
make salads
yeah i yeah when i cook
but it's so inefficient to just cook for
yourself i know
it is it's better but that's why meal
prep like i have like
i like i cook some like chicken and
like some vegetables and rice and stuff
and freeze it
i put it in the fridge i'm gonna have it
after this
i made my own like halal cart
uh shawarma local shawarma chicken and
rice
hey buddy you want spicy hot spicy
uh yeah dude those are the best man
hey that's hello i love the white sauce
yeah it's so good i tried to recreate it
it's not as good but it's close
it's crazy they can make it in a little
you know
two by two like cart and you can't even
make it with your whole kitchen
well it's just like i i didn't try that
hard like i used my own ingredients like
i didn't like
follow a recipe yeah i mean you could
probably do it if you wanted to
yeah i will
i mean you're white you don't have to be
good at middle eastern food you can just
get good at bangers and mash or
[ __ ] spotted dick bangers
i think is uh french fries or no i don't
know
yeah maybe they have so many different
names for french fries in england
chips fish and chips
damn that washing machine's really uh
yeah i think people don't think about
noise because like if you're not doing a
podcast you're like whatever the washing
machine we're like good at tuning [ __ ]
out
because we got like a super computer in
our head right
we're like we're like brain tune out
uh washing machine yeah okay
tune out crack [ __ ] hey dying in the
streets
but also your brain is hard to control
sometimes
and you can have thoughts that
are hard to
think about and hard to ignore
yes like that time
that i
um i don't know oh that time that girl
yelled at us for filming drunk people
no i don't think about that that was my
most recent
shitty thing i couldn't get out of my
head really you were
upset for a couple days i wasn't i was
upset that she would try to make me feel
bad
like i felt like she was just picking a
thing and like
going on and on about it yeah and it
felt very
evil and shitty it's like okay change
this conversation like why do you keep
on going on about it and i didn't want
to be rude
because i'm not out there to be rude to
people because i was proving my point
and then she just [ __ ] all over me and
it's like maybe i should be rude to
these [ __ ]
these drunk [ __ ] who think that
other people are
uh you know just a crop for them to use
because that's what they think
i'm not doing that she did that to me
but yeah anyways that's
that's a regret i wish i was meaner to
her
um yeah i mean
that's cool i i mean i'm sorry that you
feel bad about that
what do you do but like it's just like i
mean that's not really a regret you
didn't do anything wrong
she was in the wrong yeah so something
where i'm more that's what i appreciate
that's what i focus on is like things
that are
that i did that are embarrassing well i
do that too
like what's one of them uh
um i don't know like but like
they like they'll ha they'll happen and
it's just like something small but then
i'll forget about it like
a few weeks later and then i have a new
thing
and then i have new things but sometimes
i get embarrassed about sometimes old
ones pop up and you're like
oh i did that [ __ ] it's like it's
normally when i'm drunk
and like i just like say something
that i wouldn't have said sober or not
that
it's like a bad thing but i just like
you know
yeah act
oh one time i was on a date and there
was like a bar
and there were people right next to me
and then i was i said to my date you
look like uh you read a lot of books and
she's like what do you mean i was like
you look like a nerd
and there's a lady next to me was like
[Music]
she was like looking at me like why did
you say that like i was i felt like so
because i called a girl a nerd did she
like it
no
i mean yeah you look like a nerd
dude why is nerd so bad though because
they're not sexy
because they're in their heads they're
not in the real world they're physically
uh nerds are hot i don't know if you've
seen
revenge of the nerds
[Music]
i've never seen it um yeah
nerds are hot but
non-nerds are usually hotter
nah nerd i'm a non-nerd
i uh i'm an anti-nerd
i'm antifa and tina antifa
lobby doobie dappy
this podcast has devolved this is the
limits of our intellectual
thoughts i mean what do you want to talk
about
we should have a topic i know that's
what i'm saying
i want to talk about how i don't know
where i'm doing in life
and going and i mean i know where i'm
going i know that it's eventually going
to work out but it's just like
i don't know how to enjoy the little
things
like my big picture is very
uh focused but like
it's just like i'm just like waiting
like i'm just like
i feel like you want to do a lot of
different things because
you're insecure and you don't want to be
defined by comedy
um i'm fine with being defined by comedy
then just do comedy a bunch don't worry
about live shows but like for myself
like i don't want to do it
for myself like i wanna i wanna do other
things for myself like i'm fine with
like
if the world seems to me as a comedian
but like for me i wanna like
do other [ __ ] well you can be interested
in anything so why don't you just choose
to be interested in comedy
uh it's not a choice yeah it is
no it's not you can't just like go like
oh whatever i'm feeling right now
you gotta be like i gotta do this right
now and i'm gonna
find this interesting
no i think it's just like whatever you
want to do in that in that second
you're a slave to your emotions you're
like oh i feel like doing this
and you have to do it but if you had
more discipline you could direct
your energies dude it's just like i
don't like i don't have to do anything i
could do whatever i want in
any and in whatever i want on an
impulsive level
i know that's not a good thing yeah why
not
because it's not disciplined it's not
who cares in a direction
that's how you're supposed to live in
the moment why do you think there's a
way you're supposed to live
why do you think there's a way you're
supposed to live because one way is more
successful than the other
in terms of what in terms of
accomplishing the goals that you set out
to
accomplish well my goal is to live
that's very amorphous and not concrete
and
we'll show what dude our live chat is
spinning around
we're just following your every emotion
or dust in the wind
i mean you can do a bunch of things but
you shouldn't like
not do the comedy that is your main
focus because you think you have to do
other things
that's great i'm glad you're doing it
still
um but that wasn't even what i was
referring to what i initially brought up
with this topic
you're worried about where you're headed
in
in life um no i'm just like
i can't like i'm just like
um yeah i don't know what to do i'm just
like i'm just waiting
like i'm just like dude like i know
i know it's all gonna work out for me
but right now i'm just like
i don't know what to do in the meantime
get better at comedy
so that you can make it quicker
yeah i guess i guess yeah instead of
just like
putting around that's what i love to do
is just
lay around and lay in
my own energy but i mean we can do that
while working towards our goal like this
is pretty easy this is like
one this is not easy removed from laying
around
um this is not easy dude but relatively
like as opposed to like going out
grocery shopping
right now i wouldn't even be i wouldn't
even be talking
i would be laying down and
on my phone watching tick tocks or
i mean this is this is like something
that we can do
that will actually help us a little bit
go towards our goal
i know so that's why i want to try
at it
yeah we're doing it look at us try we're
trying so hard
this is a good try great try
this is a great learning experience for
us the learning express did you ever
um the learning in it so
dude do you remember what silly bands
were thing
no do you know silly man no
uh yeah it was when you were like in
your 20s
i think i'm a decade older than you
you're a deca dectromatist
what was your year of your birth 1998.
i'm 89. so i'm 9 years older than you
well nine years is
that long yeah
just another 10. the camera go out
yeah uh let's wrap it up
so um let's uh wrap it up
but what do you have to say about this
podcast
i think that in order
i think it's not gonna get good until i
actually put some effort into it i think
it's good that
we delved into your malaise and your
tiredness i think the way out is through
we just got to get you
as lazy and tired as possible and then
why
because then you'll be like barely
trying
and then we'll like put funny things in
front of your face and you'll say
whatever is on the top of your mind
and it'll be funny because it's like oh
like this comatose slob on the couch
is remarking on things no yes not gonna
not gonna sacrifice don't say no you uh
yes
and i'm not gonna sacrifice my
values to for comments your values are
cumbersome and inflexible being healthy
your values are preventing comedy from
happening in this moment
are we still rolling yeah
no we're not acoustically we are i don't
yeah no i'm not gonna do that i'm not
gonna it wasn't a serious
consideration it was like a hypothesis
that we could have played with but if
you just say no
and take it seriously then there's no
place
this isn't about stopping smoking weed
this is about your general malaise yeah
well i don't think i'll have it
when i stop well we can talk about it
abstractly
so that you can better handle it instead
of making it all about
a substance which is not the real root
of the problem
yes why because nancy reagan told you so
i mean don't you think that uh
your life would be better if we had a
society that was a little more
[Music]
helpful to you
no i think it's i have to solve it on my
own
you don't think you could use the group
to help you
no don't you think it'd be advantageous
if you did have the ability to use a
group to help you
why are you trying why are you doing a
political spin on this
as a group political i think it's just
i think like a lot of your problems are
not from
you and you're trying to change yourself
to fix these problems that aren't
originating from you well where
they originate from from the world we
live in
um i mean you were the you're the
creator of your own universe you can
make your life what you want it
really can you can you get health care
or change the streets outside to make it
more walkable
no you can't you'll get arrested